[Música]
bueno
supongo que todos han venido con su
pareja no
no les avisaron
levante la mano quien con pareja
unos cuantos el resto no
fíjense bien porque a lo mejor están por
ahí y no se dan cuenta
a ver piensen que hoy por hoy una pareja
es algo que cabe en un bolsillo
es más todas nuestras relaciones parecía
que caben en un bolsillo
yo por ejemplo tengo la mía saca
acá están todas las relaciones vínculos
y afectos que tengo hoy en día
o por lo menos las más importantes
porque si no están acá difícilmente
podríamos decir que son vínculos
importantes
tienen que estar agendados de alguna
forma en alguna aplicación en algún
lugar de este espacio infinito que hoy
configura la virtualidad
por eso le propongo sólo a modo de juego
que apaguemos durante el tiempo que dure
esta charla estos objetos
yo también lo voy a hacer
no se preocupen que sus vínculos van a
seguir estando cuando vuelvan a encender
o no
todos entonces ustedes y yo tenemos a
nuestros vínculos y nuestros aspectos en
el bolsillo con nosotros todo el tiempo
a ver la fantasía de tener todo en un
lugar no es nueva
atraviesa por ejemplo desde hace siglos
los sueños de la arquitectura y acá
tenemos a la obra y lo tenemos a fe de
que nos habla de ese tema
crear espacios donde tenerlo todo en un
lugar
las ciudades fueron pensadas de esa
manera
y más recientemente los hogares pensemos
en los llamados monoambientes cómo hay
que vivir esta locutora
los campos universitarios los colegios
pupilos los cuarteles los conventos y
hasta las empresas más modernas que
tienen habitaciones sala de juego
cafetería cocina hasta negocios
comerciales en la planta baja de sus
edificios todo en un lugar sin salir de
casa
en este caso sin salir de la oficina de
esas oficinas casas
otro ejemplo de este sueño de tenerlo
todo en un lugar nos lo da el lenguaje
porque que son los diccionarios sino la
fantasía de reunir todas las palabras de
una lengua en un lugar
o más aún la querida wikipedia un sitio
una vez más dónde encontrarlo todo
pero cuando hablamos de los teléfonos
modernos móviles e inteligentes no se
trata sólo del espacio de tenerlo todo
en un lugar sino también del tiempo
de tenerlo todo el tiempo y al mismo
tiempo
son si me permiten una expresión que
usaba michel foucault y trotó pías
espacios de entre los cuales encontramos
otros espacios y son también
heterogéneas es decir tiempos dentro del
tiempo
todo en un lugar todo en uno y todo al
mismo tiempo
lo cual debería hacernos pensar en otro
aspecto de la relación que tenemos con
estos teléfonos con estos objetos
insisto modernos móviles e inteligentes
porque casi con toda seguridad son el
objeto con el que más tiempo de nuestra
existencia pasamos
se han vuelto parte en esta ropa incluso
como una segunda piel o una extensión de
nosotros mismos
todos experimentamos alguna vez la
extrañeza física que nos agarra cuando
no los tenemos encima cuando lo dejamos
olvidados en algún lugar y nos faltan
hace unos meses cuando me robaron en un
arrebato el celular anterior
hasta reponer lo estaba todo el tiempo
tocando me los bolsillos como que me
faltaba algo me faltó un huevo decía que
que me pasa
pero claro es que son el primer objeto
que tocamos al despertar
y muchas veces el último que tocamos
antes de dormir
incluso hay gente que lo pone debajo de
la almohada o sea se levantan con
nosotros comen con nosotros para el baño
con nosotros duermen con nosotros quién
puede decir que tienen la relación así
tán simbiótica tan inseparable con
cualquier otro objeto persona o animal
por algo ya no se dice que los niños
vienen con un pan bajo el brazo hoy se
dice que vienen con la tablet o con un
celular bajo el brazo y tienen razón
mi hija que tiene 8 años
cada tanto me hace esta pregunta
papá en la antigüedad existían los
celulares y las tablets
así dice ya la antigüedad hablando de mi
infancia se entiende o peor me dice como
hacían en la antigüedad sin celulares en
tablets yo no podría
y parece un chiste pero yo no dice muy
en serio y también tiene razón
porque es verdad que ya no sabría cómo
vivir sin esos objetos
y quizá nosotros alguno de los cuales no
somos nativos digitales como berni
nuestros mejorador
tampoco podríamos porque hemos
desarrollado una simbiosis tal que nos
resultaría muy difícil imaginar la vida
sin estos objetos
hernán casciari un escritor argentino
que tomó mucha notoriedad a partir de su
blog offside de las historias y los
cuentos que escribía en la web y que
fueron leídos por millones de personas
en todo el mundo
con esto les quiero decir que es un tipo
que no demoniza a las nuevas tecnologías
que se sirve de ellas e incluso vive
gracias a ellas este escritorio imagina
en un relato la situación inversa a la
que se plantea mi hija no cómo sería la
vida sin la tecnología sino cómo hubiera
sido la vida en la antigüedad si
hubieran existido los teléfonos modernos
móviles e inteligentes
como en ese escritor lo piensa en la
literatura
que sería de los grandes clásicos de la
literatura sin esas historias
introdujéramos un celular
se sostendrían o perderían todo sentido
él afirma que el atractivo y el drama de
esas historias está justamente en la
incomunicación en la imposibilidad de
comunicarse con otros
soy ha tenido un celular por ejemplo
julieta le podría haber avisado a romeo
que si va a ser la muerte verse boludo
no se suicide que era todo un simulacro
para que su familia lo deje en paz
y hansel y gretel los personajes del
clásico infantil hubieran tenido un
celular no tendría que haber andado
dejando migas de pan por el camino para
nuestra viarse un activo del gps o
llamado directamente a su padre para que
los pueda buscar al lugar exacto en
donde estaba
y así muchos ejemplos
pero esto que cambiaría la historia de
la literatura cambia también
radicalmente nuestras vidas porque todos
vivimos un poco nuestra ficción y
tenemos nuestras propias historias
literarias en la cabeza y esas historias
a veces dramáticas que son las nuestras
y enamorado o enamorada
ya no tiene que andar luchando contra el
tránsito y los obstáculos físicos para
impedir que el amor de su vida se sube
un avión que los va alejar para siempre
hoy le puede mandar un whatsapp si no lo
tiene bloqueado
o llamar lo llamarla y si no te vayas te
amo no impide que el tipo la niña se
vaya a la igual pero vivimos como
si de incomunicación no fuera posible
como si estar incomunicado fuera el
octavo círculo del infierno
y basta que las tres comunicaciones se
interrumpan por un momento para que
todos nuestros lazos vínculos y afectos
de golpe y como un relámpago también
queden interrumpidos
por algo vieron que en las series en las
películas postapocalípticas siempre las
comunicaciones están jodidas como si
efectivamente un mundo sin
telecomunicaciones por el apocalipsis
por eso quisiera terminar con una
reflexión sobre las funciones que tienen
estos pequeños objetos que concentran en
un lugar y al mismo tiempo la totalidad
de nuestra vida
porque resulta obvio decir que un
teléfono sirve para hablar por teléfono
pero suele ocurrir que los objetos de
los que nos rodeamos tengan más de una
función
por ejemplo un libro es un objeto que se
parece como para ser leído
pero también se ve como objeto
decorativo o para sostener otros libros
cuando están en forma vertical o para
formar pilas en cuya superficie
colocamos a su vez otro objeto
una silla es un objeto que sirve para
sentarse sin embargo nos falta quien se
suba a ella sobre todo cualquiera
alcanzar algún lugar inaccesible y hay
la silla funciona como una escalera
es decir rara vez encontramos esa
correspondencia ideal entre el objeto y
su función
por lo tanto no debería sorprendernos
que la versatilidad de algunos objetos
amplíe tanto su uso a veces incluso de
manera muy alejada a la que fueron
pensados originalmente
es el caso de los teléfonos modernos
pero en particular de estos de los
móviles e inteligentes porque su
inteligencia está justamente en esa
multiplicidad de funciones que nos
brindan
en ese sentido esta multiplicidad de
funciones no la encontrábamos en los
viejos teléfonos esos que hoy están en
vías de extinción vieron que son más
frecuentes encontrarlos en la feria
retro que en la casa de cada uno
por eso existen en las oficinas donde
claro se espera que la gente esté quieta
fija y con escasa movilidad
aquellos teléfonos los fijos quizás eran
los únicos que merecerían la definición
de objeto para comunicarse en forma oral
con alguien que está a una distancia
mayor del alcance de nuestros ojos
porque en ellos el prefijo tele
distancia y fono sonido se conjugan bien
pero en el caso de los teléfonos
modernos móviles inteligentes el nombre
como que les queda chico o grande
grande porque la familia de las
telecomunicaciones se ha ampliado y hoy
un sinnúmero de dispositivos nos brindan
las más propiedades es posible
comunicarse atrás de una computadora a
una notebook la netbook la tablet pero
también el nombre les queda chico porque
han ampliado tanto sus funciones que ya
no tienen el rol de ser un simple
intercomunicador
los teléfonos los nuevos ya no sirven
sólo para hablar
en ese sentido es como si la obviedad se
hubiera desplazado
si antes lo obvio era con un teléfono
sirve para hablar por teléfono hoy lo
obvio es que nos sirven sólo para eso
pero para qué sirven
no es tan sencillo responder por cuando
algo sirve para muchas cosas
difícilmente podamos decir que sirve
específicamente para algo
pero yo les diría así rápidamente que
una catarata de verbos podríamos
enumerar
hablar chatear o mensajear o a zapear
emoticones fotografiar filmar grabar
mirar fotos y videos y de llamar
facebook y twitter
stalker limpiar subir fotos etiquetar
gustar escuchar música descargar música
conocer el pronóstico del tiempo
-hubiera calcular comprar en un libro
jugar
pelea y discutía a distancia
capturar borrar eliminar bloquear contar
los pasos dados antes caminamos liberar
hacer la lista del super contabilizar
dibujar voltear compartir escanear
conectar desconectar internar para
rankear cronometrar a robar
peinar y hasta depilar porque viene que
hay gente que lo usa como espejo para
maquillarse
ante semejante despliegue de funciones
quizá podríamos haciendo la pregunta
inversa
para que nos sirven realmente sirven
para todo
y ahí si nos dejamos llevar son otros
verbos los que empiezan a aparecer
besar
acariciar
abrazar cojer
perfumar alimentar bañar vacunar
sostener llorar reír cuidar contener
porque a ver sin dudas todos disfrutamos
y agradecemos la posición que tenemos de
comunicarnos con otros al instante
no tienes que esperar meses y meses a
que llegue una carta para tener
novedades
o simplemente poder hablar con alguien
que tenemos a miles de kilómetros de
distancia
sin embargo quien puede decir que en
algún momento esas otras funciones que
no nos brindan
como darle un beso en los labios a
alguien dar y recibir una caricia o
poder abrazarnos como estamos pasando un
mal momento no son tan importantes como
las funciones que si nos dan
porque un teléfono moderno móvil e
inteligente puede ser besado
pero no sirve para besar
un teléfono moderno móvil inteligente
puede ser acariciado
pero no sirve para acariciar
un teléfono moderno móvil e inteligente
a fin de cuentas nos puede despertar
pero nos hace soñar muchas gracias
[Aplausos]
[Música]